but luke we got to get for we got to get
real we got to get serious there is
serious harm that may be coming for all
of us and it's this story right here
group of monkeys kill over 250 dogs for
revenge in indian town what if they come
for us what i'm just kidding
about friday night
friday night and we're gonna we're gonna
we're gonna leave on a on a it's not
actually a good note this is actually
horrible yeah this is volume two of our
books
i read the story and i felt depressed
like seriously it's sad what's happening
is there a video there's video oh my god
don't group of monkeys i need to know
what happened no this is a video of them
rescuing a puppy from the monkey so look
at this
a group of monkeys in a small town in
india took revenge on the local dog
population by throwing them off the top
of buildings and trees it's reported the
monkeys have killed about 250 pups in
the process and are targeting villagers
the monkeys located in malagan india
started the rampage after some of the
dogs allegedly killed an infant monkey
news 18 reported that when the monkey
sees a dog approach they catch them and
throw them from a significant height to
the ground in the neighboring village of
lavool the monkeys have eradicated all
of the dogs
after all the dogs were killed in the
village residents contacted forest
department officials to catch the
monkeys but when officials attempted to
catch the monkeys they were unable to
capture a single monkey villagers
believe the monkeys are taking revenge
on the dogs now villagers and level are
being chased by the monkeys some have
even been attacked quote we've seen that
when an individual is attacked in some
way the likelihood of them attacking
someone related to their their aggressor
is higher
typically there's a preference for
attacking a third party associated with
the original aggressor as opposed to the
actual aggressor for the most part these
acts of revenge take place shortly after
the attack
all right we got real serious throughout
the previous segments
this one's actually kind of a messed up
story but at least we can wind down on a
friday night and get our minds out of
that dark place and talk about monkeys
the dogs are reading too much brian
stelter yeah
the monkeys are yeah maybe the monkeys
were the the monkeys or the monkeys uh i
was gonna make a communist reference but
i should have i'm gonna stop myself
there the monkeys have been on facebook
reading about how dogs are evil and they
just wanted all the dogs to drop dead
and they went out there and started
throwing dogs off roofs i spent some
time i spent some time in india the the
monkeys there call the shots i mean
seriously if you're i i mean around the
taj mahal area in
mumbai
there's literally people making money
off people going on beaches monkeys rob
them and then you pay the locals a few
dollars and they'll get your stuff back
but uh in india
especially outside of the taj mahal
there's monkeys running around all over
the place and and they're like if they
want something from you they're gonna
get it we need cassandra's view on this
story yeah i was thinking
she's become a rather a bit of a monkey
expert oh yeah do you guys see that that
crazy video where during the lockdown
the the baboons had no food so there
were roving gangs of baboons attacking
each other for food
like they they it was like they went
bloods and crips you know like we're in
the dystopia
yeah you know there that that's right
you know rise of the planet of the apes
i figured yeah i think i'd like to title
our reality the omega variant
you know like because that's the last
variant you know that's where we're
headed and it sounds cool the omega
variant and because you know we're in a
sci-fi dystopia with all of this stuff
going on yeah and i i would just like to
call it that yeah the only place that's
safe is the metaverse
that's part of the variance oh yeah
there's also monkey castles in india
where monkeys get worshipped and there's
monkey tribes fighting other monkey
tribes for the top position of their
group to be inside of this monkey casual
monkey castle where they get worshipped
by the locals and fed by the locals so
there's also stories of monkeys
attacking people because of a lack of
tourists in other south asian countries
and just hordes of monkeys uh just
pretty much
running entire cities in south asia new
thing piece from newsweek can monkeys be
racist let's find out
well it depends what's the race of the
dogs are the dogs chocolate labs are
yellow they're white adjacent
are they yeah they're white passing yeah
yeah white passing dogs well this dog is
actually white on its front and brown on
its back so
i don't know mixed it's it's white
passing oh yeah by passing there's any
amount of white in there no good no good
the monkeys are going to come for us
it's true it's a new michael bay movie
did you did you there was a show i was
watching it was called like after humans
or something i forgot what it's called
and they said that if huma if humans
disappeared right now if every single
person on the planet which is gone house
cats would take over
yeah because they're the only they
reproduce like crazy
and they're the only species besides
humans that kill for fun oh yeah
yeah they hunt for fun they kill for fun
and so they just needlessly destroy and
expand and kill and man
cats dude not a fan of cats oh yeah
they're like they're torturers like they
literally torture animals for fun my cat
brings me a decapitated mouse yeah quite
often yeah that's great it's treasure we
had uh vocus our cat he was uh we went
outside and had he was holding a bird a
little bluebird and then he would it was
its wing was busted so he would let it
go and it would struggle and jump off
and then he would pounce it and whack it
and whack it and whack it we had to put
the bird down it was this little tiny
little tiny bird because like it had
been eviscerated and so we were like
what do we do like we just gotta you
know and then there was another time
where i saw him sitting in the grass
looking around and i went out there and
there was a little mouse on its back
just like wheezing
and then it rolled over and started to
crawl away and then he just got ready
and then he let it go a little bit then
he jumped up and started bashing it over
and over again so i took a little stick
and i put it under the hand of the mouse
and the mouse grabbed onto it and i
lifted it up and he was just hanging
there dangling and and boca started
going
like yelling at me and then i put the
mouse in a bush i think he survived
because buck is just beating him but he
didn't he didn't gut him or anything
like that nice cats are brutal yeah well
mouse rescuer you want to know what's
the most brutal thing i saw okay it's
one thing when bokus is like stalking
the mouse and and and swatting it a
mouse was walking past the chicken coop
and a chicken ran over and grabbed it
bashed the mouse with its beak against
against the ground and then just
swallowed it whole and i was like oh my
god that's like some ancient dna
pterodactyl stuff little dinosaurs man
dude it just swallows it's like oh yeah
that's all no that i i didn't see that
happen i was told by uh some of the
people here that like they saw it grab
the mouse and just bash it and then
and i was like whoa they eat your
protein and eggs yeah yeah dude they eat
they eat chicken yeah nature is you know
that chickens will eat each other yeah
of course so we had we had uh one of our
chickens yeah dorothy one of our
chickens was was getting injured
i gotta be honest dorothy is kind of a
[ __ ]
hold on she's not here to defend herself
she was attacking she was bullying the
other chickens
and so the other chickens teamed up and
roberto the rooster started he would
jump on her and he wasn't he wasn't he
wasn't doing the business because you
know like he would just jump on her
pecking her head like crazy and then she
would scream and run away and her back
was all all messed up
and so i we i looked it up we had people
comment on the show they said if she
starts bleeding the other chickens will
peck her to death and then eat the body
so we we separated him for about two or
three weeks dorothy fully healed we
reintroduced her they're all getting
along just fine now it's fantastic we're
getting the cameras out of our chat so
there's hope you're saying for people
yeah
you just got to separate them
yeah well so a couple weeks is the
equivalent to a chicken of maybe like a
year yeah six months none of these
chickens are dorothy's a uh a year and a
half old wow the the other adult
chickens are were born in january so
they're almost a year
so they were separated for about three
weeks
right so that's like you know maybe like
a year or two years of their lives and
reintroduce them and they'll be like
shane i haven't seen you in so long yeah
i can't remember why we were mad at each
other you know i want to eat you
i'm okay
are you injured
hey guys he is injured that's food
as humans right now we are so lucky and
so protected from the realities of
nature uh because
again like if if ish starts to get real
if there's going to be a lack of
resources a lack of food it's going to
be a very natural process of what's
going to be taking place and a lot of us
are not used to nature a lot of us are
not used to the wild not a lot of us
don't even understand how the wild works
and i think you know with all the crazy
stuff happening i think people are going
to get a very rude awakening so i think
i'd be in a very left i was raised by
like a crazy prepper like a doomsday
prepper
yeah we had like we literally had like a
go trailer like in the garage that we
could like hook up and just go we never
had to use it but
i was just raised that way i think i
would survive an apocalypse vehicle yes
we did
yeah
are there some like other prepper tips
that you would share with people that
you learned i learned a lot of weird
stuff as a child like i mean i was in
middle school like chopping down bamboo
that just kind of randomly grew i live
on the edge of like uh seneca creek
which is off of the potomac and it's my
house kind of backs up to the woods and
there's like a kind of random shoot of
bamboo that shot up i think for privacy
for my neighbor but there's a bunch of
dead uh bamboo down there in middle
school i would take it and wrap a
fishing line around it and catch
salamanders and catch catfish in the
sunken creek and i was like that was
like my little like teenage girl thing i
had no friends and i was like oh my god
why does that why does everyone think
i'm weird but like just like little
stuff like that that was normal to me
growing up i learned how to um like uh
treat and clean campion from pine trees
to eat and make tea with i learned how
to make like flour from acorns a lot of
weird stuff like that
acorns
do you ever make dandelion tea
yeah ian talks about that a lot mm-hmm
he was like yo we got to make dinner
lots of awesome
i really like it yeah i love it pine tea
from made from cambium is also pretty
good i've made acorn tea as well or like
it's kind of more of like a nutty coffee
flavor if you do it with acorns but yeah
we got probably 300 pounds of black
walnut outside you ever do anything with
that
it's apparently like an anti-parasitic
or something but you're not supposed to
like eat a lot of it i don't know i
don't know
we have paw paw like crazy in october
though remember the day i met you you
made mulberry jam yeah blueberry jam you
maybe gave me a cookie with some
mulberry jam we made amazing the best
thing we made
so we have wild wine berries everywhere
in west virginia i saw a guy driving on
the highway pull over his car jump out
and start grabbing berries from the side
of the road i'm not kidding they're
delicious they're like a chinese
raspberry we took those and we took
lemon juice now you use a little bit of
lemon juice you're making a jam but i
did a lot of lemon juice to make a lemon
wineberry jam
it was amazing and then we made we put
it on cheesecake
so good i got news though i got good
news
we were trying to get this building
built we got a building getting built
nice we're going to have freedom stand
tim cast hq an official big steel
construct building 7 500 square feet
with a new studio being built out
specifically inside of it we got this
confirmed today i didn't think we'd be
able to pull it off because of the
shortages and the price increases but we
finally found a company that said we can
get this done
it's smaller than we originally wanted
but it's going to be mostly big empty
open space for now and then there's
going to be a small area that's about 20
feet by 75 feet that will comprise the
studio it's going to be a second floor
construct and then we're going to have a
legit headquarters in west virginia for
everything we're still going to have
this space for production and editorial
and everything but we're growing like
crazy it's incredible yeah we're growing
like mad crazy
it's good news yeah and it's thanks to
everybody who's a member who's a member
at timcast.com supporting all of us all
the work we do and uh it's a hefty
ticket like it's it's expensive to do
but it's like i've been saying
we want we want to do a lot we need
space we want to do the the truth and
media foundation we want to fact check
the fake media we need office space for
this we want to do the technology stuff
we need office space for this so we're
going to start building out the space we
need it's actually cheaper to build on
this land than it would be to go buy a
building and deal with it plus it's
going to be built made to order so it's
specifically for us and everything we
need
man it's crazy that we're getting this
stuff done so hopefully you know i'll
put it this way the fact that this is
all happening is the best evidence that
we are winning that success is not only
possible but it's happened before it's
happening now and is going to continue
happening so that's good news for for
that's a very optimistic thing i think
and i also want to add because someone
super chatted this that i am in fact a
pokemon he is yes uh it's a pokemon
called tim paul
literally it's called temple
and it's the pokemon wearing headphones
kind of looks like you it does and it's
got the same colors
yeah isn't that really weird who came
first i love him uh tim pool was made
well before i was using it's really
crazy the colors we use for tim cast
the the name tim paul simulation and
yeah simulation for sure
but i so like we use the teal and the
black as the colors on the website he
swims not weird yeah that's weird tim
maybe the true version of you in the
alternate reality a part of this larger
kind of consciousness that we're a part
of was just kind of trolling
someone
i don't know but somebody somebody
somebody super chat they're like why
didn't you tell us that you were a uh
pokemon and i was like other people have
sent us this before tim paul temple
that's weird so weird yeah it's like a
tadpole i guess yeah yep so cute
well that's that's even the right water
sign how funny yeah that is and i'm a
pisces yeah exactly as i'm saying yeah
your water sign great funny
so do we live in a simulation pick up
your copy of copy of the inverted world
book and burrito perfect look at that
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more
unfiltered and uncensored content with
all of these guests go to timcast.com
and become a member all of these guests
you know and love in exclusive segments
on our website where we are unrestricted
in what we talk about so you'll
definitely not want to miss it thanks
for hanging out we'll see you all next
time
you